So now that we've built it ourselves, I'm going to show
you the easy way to do it, which is to
use the built in Python type called a dictionary. And
what a dictionary is is really an implementation of a hash
table. It's built into Python. So it's much easier to
use than defining our own hash table. So far, we've
seen two complex types in Python. We've seen the string
type and we've seen the list type. Now we're going to introduce
the dictionary type. So there are many things that are
common between these three. There are other things that are
different. So to create a string we could have a
sequence of characters inside quotes. To create a list, we
use the square bracket. And we could have a sequence
of elements inside the square bracket, and the elements could
be any type, unlike a string where they had to
be characters. So, our string was a sequence of characters.
Our list was a list of any kind of value. So, a list of elements of any value.
The dictionary type we're going to create using the curly
bracket. And the entries inside the dictionary are key
value pairs. So here I've created a dictionary with
two elements. And each element, the key is a
string. Here is the string hydrogen and the value
associated with that element is a number. The keys
in a dictionary can be any immutable value, so they don't
need to be strings, they could be numbers. They could be
other things. The values can be any value. So what a
dictionary is, is a set of key value pairs and the property
that a dictionary will give us is like the hash table,
that we can look up a key and get a value associated
with that key. So one important property of all types is
whether they're immutable or mutable. We saw that the string was immutable.
That means once we create a string, we can't
modify that string. It has the same value it always
has. A list was mutable, we could change the values
of elements in the list after we create the list.
We could append to the list, adding new elements
to it. A dictionary is also mutable. So after we
create a dictionary, we could add new key value pairs
to it. We could change the value of values associated
with keys. We saw with strings, if s is a string, then we can do s index i.
That will give us the ith letter in the
string. With lists, we can do something very similar. If
p is a list, we can do p index i to get the ith element of the list. With
dictionaries, it's a little bit different. The syntax is
the same. We can do d index k. With both
strings and lists, these were numbers. Here the k is
whatever the key value is. So this is a key
in the dictionary. What d index k will give us
the value associated with that key in the dictionary. We'll
see some examples soon. We can also use our indexing
and assignments. We saw, with the list, we could do
this. That would replace the value of the ith element
of p with whatever we have here. With the string,
we can't do that. That produces an error.
And the reason we can't do it is because
strings are immutable. So there's no way to
modify characters in a string. With the dictionary we
can. And what the meaning of this, is
very similar to the meaning of update in our
hash table. So that's equivalent to update the
value. The value associated with k to be v.